[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Бессарабія
Національний природний парк
«Тузловські лимани»]
Тут можна побачити дуже цікавих птахів.
Ірино Михайлівно, гляньте
на наших червонодзьобих качок.
[Іван Русєв
Еколог]
Гляньте!
Ірина Михайлівна – головний
природознавець Бессарабії.
Насправді я жартую.
Вона головний природознавець Національного природного парку «Тузловські лимани».
Фактично, у межі національного парку
входять водно-болотні угіддя,
яких охороняють як місця
перебування водоплавних птахів.
Тому для нас основним об'єктом охорони є птахи.
[Ірина Вихристюк
Еколог]
Гляньте, будь ласка!
Це червононосий нирок.
Він є в Червоній книзі України.
Це руда чапля летить.
Вона летить через Сахару
у Центральну Африку зимувати.
Дуже рідко можна її зустріти.
Я вивчав територію та природні явища
Українського Причорномор'я багато років.
Насамперед, я спостерігав за дельфінами.
Коли я бачу їх у дельфінаріях,
то вважаю це великою трагедією.
Я прийшов сюди для того,
щоб зробити кращі умови,
щоб дельфіни відчували себе спокійно.
Ми зараз у гирлі річки Когильник
і у верхів'ях лиману Сасик.
Чорноморський лиман Сасик — це найбільший
лиман на Північно-Західному Причорномор'ї.
Недарма його називали
«пологовим будинком Чорного моря».
Тому що це є унікальним місцем для відтворення
усього різноманіття Чорного моря.
Це був лиман, який давав великі рибні
та рекреаційні ресурси для місцевого населення.
Я в дитинстві тут ловив рибу та
насолоджувався краєвидами цього лиману.
Я мріяв стати екологом та біологом,
щоб дізнатися, як живе ця система.
У 1978 році територія
між цим лиманом та Чорним морем
була перебудована у «Велику Китайську стіну».
Це був проєкт «Водогосподарський комплекс:
Дунай, Дністер, Дніпро».
Передбачалося віддамбування
майже усіх чорноморських лиманів аж до Дніпра.
Сасик був першим на шляху.
Узагалі, за проєктом Сасику
відводилась роль відстійника.
Побудували Дунай-Дністровська
зрошувальну систему.
52 тисячі гектар мали зрошуватись.
Але, в результаті, 30 тисяч гектар було осолонцьовано.
Для нас, місцевих мешканців,
це є глобальною проблемою.
Тому що ресурси лиману зараз
не можна використовувати.
Ми маємо цілу низку проблем,
які в кінцевому результаті
відображаються на здоров'ї
та достатку місцевого населення.
Ми писали дуже багато листів
та організовували пікети місцевій владі.
Нам дуже опирались
місцева та районна влада.
Я був здивований цьому рівню
корупції у маленькій Бессарабії,
що у Татарбунарському районі.
Також нерозумінню місцевих жителів,
які питали для чого цей парк був створений.
Та великій зажерливості браконьєрів.
Я сказала, що не заспокоюсь,
допоки ми не дамо свободи Сасику.
Його свобода — це розвиток.
Ми маємо показувати, як не можна втручатися
в природу, бо самі постраждаємо від цього.
Мені хочеться повернути те,
що було в моєму дитинстві.
Я хочу, щоб мої онуки жили
в безпечному середовищі.
Я хочу, щоб у них було
хоча б таке дитинство, як у мене.
Природний стан Сасика —
це морський лиман.
А для того, щоб це був морський лиман,
ми маємо відновити
природний зв'язок з Чорним морем.
Технічних проблем немає.
Якщо територія буде віднесена
до національного природного парку,
то має бути відновлена протока
з двома або одним каналом до 300 метрів,
який забезпечить водообмін.
І тоді будуть запущені механізми самовідновлення.
Природа має надзвичайно потужний потенціал.
Ми роздамбували декілька дамб у дельті Дністра
і відновили місця годівлі птахів.
Але немає островів,
де вони можуть звити гнізда.
Зараз ми маємо маленьку вже завершену програму,
яка орієнтується на те, щоб збудувати 42 гнізда
для дуже рідкісного птаха чоботаря,
що у Червоній книзі України.
Я мрію, щоб усі поважали цю унікальну територію,
щоб сюди приїжджали туристи
і щоб ми показали перед міжнародною спільнотою,
що являємось цивілізованим колективом
і цивілізованою країною.
Ми сподіваємося, що у нас буде більше волонтерів.
Це дуже важка праця, але ми шукаємо
натхнення у нашій унікальній природі
та у наших стосунках
з місцевими мудрими людьми.
І ми переможемо.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко
Марія Теребус]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Субтитрувальниця
Ярина Фаюра]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]